satisfaction sur l'accomplissement après
c'est pas une fin en soi mais c'est déjà
pas mal
sanofi tive que j'étais fier que j'ai
aussi raté alors comment ça se passe au
club de nîmes
non ça se passe callian dès mon arrivée
j'ai tout de suite été à l'aise donc le
dans l'équipe même dans la ville donc ça
s'est très bien passé
quand je suis arrivé enfin revenant d
les il semblait pas on est tous je vous
remets tes accueilli bien accueilli par
les coaches les entraîneurs le staff du
coup ça a permis de bien évoluer de me
sentir vraiment à l'aise et de
progresser le club
c'est une bonne intégration pour un
jeune est ce qu il yad autres antillo
guyanais
quand je suis arrivé on était 2 du coup
c'est un peu c'est déjà bien
et au fur et mesure plus années verront
passer puis à des antilles du annexe est
arrivé maintenant on commence à être pas
mal dans l'équipe mais on a un qui en
est le clip tourné puis année en
guadeloupe un steven genre on avait dit
il en garde en ce début de saison mais
qui est partie à la mi saison et après
on a pas mal de 8,6
comme nicolas ne sauvera pas mal de
métis donc le seront pas
aujourd'hui le club de nîmes se présente
parmi le top 5 du hand en
sur le plan national on a fait une bonne
saison très belle saison on a réussi à
finir cinquième c'était l'objectif de la
saison qui ont réussi à obtenir beaucoup
l'année prochaine la coupe d'europe
c'est vraiment une bonne belle saison
commençait à réaliser
il n'y a pas de lui ce qu'elles sont à
venir quels sont ses objectifs pour les
prochaines années pour la prochaine
année bien continuer à travailler à
progresser a évolué à évoluer au sein de
nos équipes pour ne plus de
responsabilisation sabilité plus de
temps de jeu et qu'on peut devenir local
au patron de l'équipe
donc au début c'était difficile pour moi
de changer de passer derrière gauche à
deux défenseurs mais au fur à mesure
j'ai accepté j'ai eu aussi je bossais a
pas mal de joueurs autour de moi qui me
met qui me donne des conseils aux
syndics du groupe de couches comme en ce
moment me sentir bien et à être pas mal
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que ça a
été facile
l'intégration est ce qu'il y à aussi la
peau familiale maman papa etc
oui j'ai fait j'ai eu là je fais j'ai la
chance d'avoir des parents qui n'ont
souvent soutenu suivi dit même quand
j'ai terminé mes parents m'ont toujours
encouragé à faire ce que je voulais
faire mais je dis que je voulais faire
du handball que c'était ma passion en
cinglais donc mes parents m'ont toujours
soutenu et aidé donc tout ça m'a aidé
vraiment